je fais le tirage au sort dimanche soit
salut pour ce nouveau master class je
vais vous parler d'une technique pour
retenir les prénoms des personnes
un test a été réalisé lorsque deux
personnes se rencontrent ont donné des
informations et on a regardé ce qui
était le mieux retenu 69 % des
participants ont retenu le métier 68 %
des participants ont retenu les loisirs
de la personne 69 et 68 ça fait pas 100%
c'est normal c'est à chaque fois on
s'intéressait qu'à un sujet et ont
vérifié le nombre de personnes qui
avaient retenu ce sujet là 62 % des
participants avaient retenu la ville
dont venaient la personne 31 % des
participants avaient retenu le prénom et
30% le nom de famille et ça me conforte
dans les discussions que j'ai avec les
spectateurs la fin des spectacles c'est
quand même la chose qui revient le plus
à mes oreilles quand on parle de mémoire
le bas moi j'ai beaucoup de mal à
retenir le visage et le prénom des gens
heureusement il ya des techniques pour
savoir faire ça je vais vous apprendre
ce master class tout d'abord qu'on vous
présente quelques uns il faut accorder
un vrai temps de concentration comme
quand on veut apprendre quelque chose
malheureusement souvent quand on demande
le prénom de quelqu'un on les écoute que
d'une oreille on le classe en mémoire
immédiate c'est juste pour le répéter
derrière et on passe à autre chose
on n'accorde pas notre attention
pleinement à ce sujet là quand vous
présente quelqu'un il faut vous
recentrez quelques secondes
oubliez un peu ce qui se passe se
focaliser sur la personne se disant ok
j'ai envie de la rencontrer
quel est votre prénom et met toute son
attention sur ce moment une fois que la
personne dit son prénom vous devez le
répéter vous même à voix haute
ça va l'inscrire un petit peu plus
longtemps dans votre mémoire et surtout
vous allez vous entendre vous même le
prononcer dont vous allez travailler
également votre mémoire auditive
ce qui donnerait bonjour quand vous
appelez team mantallot enchanté team
mantallot moi c'est fabien oui parce que
je veux oui je vous ai donné un prénom
collectif aujourd'hui ensuite
immédiatement imaginé sur le front de la
personne son prénom soit à tous et soit
écrit en gros avec un feutre le
président roosevelt faisait ça lui il
imaginait un coup de tampon un coup de
tampon encreur donc comme écrit avec un
tampon visualiser ça essayez juste
d'imaginer son prénom écrite à trouver
ou dessiner sur son front pas forcément
en noir d'ailleurs ça peut être dans
votre couleur préférée ou de la couleur
préférée de la personne vous pouvez vous
amuser avec cette petite visualisation
qui prend quelques secondes à peine
durant tout ce processus ne lâchez pas
du regard la personne vous pouvez
continuer à parler avec l essayer de
replacer le prénom le plus souvent que
vous le pouvez
si par exemple c'est au cours d'une
soirée que la personne s'en va à faire
autre chose vous la recroiser la soirée
tout de suite remplacé le prénom le fait
de le répéter ça va commencer à le caler
dans une mémoire un petit peu plus à
long terme et j'ai un type c'est une
astuce qui fonctionne très bien pour
associer le dise
jean même temps au prénom c'est de
trouver soit un moyen mnémotechnique si
on me présente quelqu'un qui s'appelle
sébastien fait l'imaginer dans le
générique de belle et sébastien avec le
chien à côté de lui etc
si on présente dit rien qui s'appelle
jean paul v l'imaginer en blanc en pape
dans une pas pour mobiles en train de
faire bon jour et si j'ai pas forcément
une et ma technique immédiat qui me
vient je prends soin d'acteurs célèbres
soit quelqu'un que je connais si je
rencontre quelqu'un qui s'appelle jean
je vais l'imaginé avec jean dujardin
les deux l'un à côté de l'autre comme ça
comme s'il était juste à côté de lui qui
se tenait limite par l'épaule et
intérieurement je me dirais gens comme
jean
ça aussi ça prend que quelques secondes
et ça permet de fixer beaucoup mieux
l'information dans le temps si vous
prenez le temps de faire ça correctement
et systématiquement la prochaine fois
que vous allez recroiser la personne
vous allez vous souvenir de son prénom
et si vous ne l'avez pas retenu il y a
la très bonne méthode de reagan
j'avais lu dans une biographie que
jacques chirac l'utiliser également
cette méthode c'est une méthode digne
d'un petit mentalist a embrouillé tout
d'abord reagan montrer qui se
souvenaient qui était la personne donc
il y parlait de la ville où ils
s'étaient rencontrés ou de la ville où
habitait la personne ou du métier de la
personne ou des hobbies de la personne
comme on l'a vu dans le test en début de
vidéo c'est les informations qu'on
retient le mieux en clair ils envoyaient
le message qui se souvenaient qui était
la personne sans avoir besoin de re
prononcer le prénom est un peu plus loin
de la conversation il disait cette
phrase magique
par contre ça m'échappe rappelez moi
comment vous appelez déjà si la personne
disait son prénom alors reagan enchaîné
en disant dans mes votre prénom
évidemment je les ai pas oubliés c'est
votre nom de famille qui m'échappe et
vous l'avez compris si la personne visée
sans doute famille disait oui je me
souvenais de votre nom de famille par
contre c'est sûr votre prénom que j'ai
un léger doute c'était une magnifique
car wet qu'on peut utiliser qu'une seule
fois par personne c'est à utiliser
vraiment avec modération mais ça
fonctionne
j'espère que grâce à cette vidéo vous
allez mieux retenir les prénoms à partir
d'aujourd'hui fait le sait très efficace
et très simple à mettre en place il ya
pas besoin de d'entraînement il ya juste
besoin de penser à le faire en clair si
vous le voulez vous allez y arriver si
vous avez trouvé que cette vidéo vous
serez d'une quelconque utilité vous
pouvez me le faire savoir en n'oubliant
pas de laisser un commentaire elle déjà
pouce en l'air
vous pouvez également commenter la vidéo
puisque je lis tous vos commentaires
vraiment chaque jour j'aime bien faire
ça et surtout pensez à vous abonner
avant de partir puisque le mental blog
c'est une vidéo par jour pendant un an
il ya le calendrier de la chaîne dans le
descriptif donc rendez vous demain à 11h
ciao